louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
nosotros somos mukluks
no rosemary corners YouTube heroes yes
yeah
air move off Susan resistant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
avocado yes Senora Wojcicki as visto una
one days no naka de needed plus a repair
uno in Persona seven dortch's Gino
gordita come on baby
pure meant the day it releases grantees
the Rompin Lomita siga-me no club same
pain piazza della Vita is la mejor de
con West Was SPD's home and is Jesus can
capture joy Sparrow a miss master step
good ice okay Mankato
no ste Hendo Savion clasificado 's a
novecientos or grassy own Eskimo grupo
so do la mejor oportunidad de tomba
Ranma club moon near poor pero no era
say trotters anacondas to the Coleman
Maradona Chino next door
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the third chairs too cool
for school right now a little neat breed
if I do I'm a big fan of course defend
Gavin calm Gavin McInnes how are you sir
hello everyone how are you
I see what you did there see usually a
hat would be worn under the head clothes
well if your hat has a brim then you
have to wear it on top of your
headphones and it takes intense
balancing but I was an African woman for
many years and we would go and collect
water from a river that was about a four
miles from our mud hut was this in a
previous life or just when you were a
racist no I identified as an African and
then someone said why don't you move to
my hut next to the war and I had never
thought of that and I stopped caring
water my head no sense but you still
were they had a Morgan Jr what's the one
of the days Lange twins Pinot Noir land
of the Lange twins leaving it at the
rest stop what question of the day we're
going to be talking about Jack Dorsey of
course that's been the topic of this
week where do you line up here it's a
time for the government to regulate big
tech as public utilities I know there's
some different opinions on the right I'm
not quite there we talked about it
turning Ash Wednesday yesterday yeah I
will run through the clips of Joe Rogan
and Sam Harrison in all the stuff going
on with Jack Dorsey right before we get
to that happy Valentine's Day at 1:00
this morning in my heart just about sank
through my bottom I genuinely forgot
about Valentine's Day did you really yes
Slade didn't Oh Slade is actually
claiming that Donald Trump is ruining
sex this comes from twice second post
Trump sex disorder they claim Donald
Trump created feelings of fear loathing
and of just not wanting to have sex so
yeah amongst your other personal
problems you can now blame Trump for
your sexual dysfunction unsurprisingly
though Pfizer has already developed a
drug to help okay
have you been struggling with an
embarrassing problem for frankly like
the last two years does reading Fox and
BuzzFeed ok leave you feeling like that
quite a bad do presidents Trump's witty
tweets leave your food sauce that
frankly Trump Alice okay is for you
Trump Alice do not use truck posturing
historic job throw from palaces not
covered by Obamacare Trump Alice May got
the effective at your vegan drive an
electric car live in San Francisco
actions from to tell us may last for
years for direction last a second term
consultant position of is pretty much
nothing to do Trump Alice not for back
tickets you know what something he's not
person who should be narrator that's I
agree with everything you've been saying
by the way jokes are my reality now yeah
my sex life has been hurt by Trump my
wife doesn't like Trump and i thinkin I
don't think Mexicans have a problem with
with the wrecked-tile dysfunction oh I
don't know there are so many of them are
Catholic also we should note that your
wife doesn't like Trump because you do
refer to your small member as Trump
that's the international news there was
an explosion in a German chocolate
foundry yeah
the fire fighters closed off that worry
about to say don't do that you sounded
like Bill super foot Wallis in the first
UFC tears when he was commentating he
goes in with fighting google bill super
foot Wallis and it was lost the fights
hadn't even started German Java factory
exploded this comes from NBC News the
fire fighters closed off the street and
shoveled the chocolate 108 square feet
and surprise they don't use meters here
to one sight before a specialist
cleaning company clean the road
unfortunately that specialty cleaning
company turned out to be a refugee rape
gang led by none other than the
notorious Augustus Mohammed gloop yeah
that was sad to find look at the monster
you three minutes on the relocker look
at the monster I don't I don't feel good
about bringing Gene Wilder into this no
no I was an aberration
Nation of Islam you're like that's a sad
waste of chocolate right there
especially on Valentine's Day come on
sad waste of a good gene Wilder
impression what it's not what I wanted
to take that out turning the 2020 race
because that interests Gavin I know
that's gone you know if Trump loses
apparently that's true do you find
yourself conflicted what do you mean
well 20 cups of sex is no conflict don't
take it anywhere in any way shape or
form yeah but you so Cory Booker can
count on your vote
oh whoa a bit too far what am i
conflicted about Trump well no because
you said your sex life was harmed by yes
no no I don't masturbate
so what sex is sex is happening it right
it's almost like sorry
like as I walk towards her I'm like
sorry either for this ride you knew what
your vows involuntary here you mentioned
that you'd Gary Wilson on your show when
he talked about that guys who weren't
using pornography were chasing their
wives around and most wives like it
unfortunately what if you masturbate and
you watch porn and your wife puts you in
the doghouse you're like fine I'll set
up in the doghouse you know when she
cuts out the spigot and there's no other
option it sucks to be in the doghouse
sounds like she's a lot of control over
you turning to the 2020 race Cory Booker
speaking what she claimed that our
planet simply can't sustain people
eating meat no it can't this is what he
said the vegan presidential candidate
there's her those are words I never
thought I would say you know the time
that the Taft isn't concerned about meat
consumption he warned at the greenhouse
gas greenhouse gas is produced by the
industry or quote not practical and
unfortunately led to the decline in
stock prices for dairy futures Tyson
Foods in the Swift execution of all
participating dancers at New Jersey's
beef cakes yeah so unintended
consequences yeah that's the wrong beef
I think yeah I don't think it's the
wrong beef well it's just a different
flavor okay I'm gonna say no to that you
the point here there are Kevin I believe
so no doing the show pitch you mention
New York and abortion something like
that oh yeah another great way to reduce
carbon emissions
sorry you're calling back to something
from like 80 hours ago another great
thing about you you wrote it down it's
in front of you in my face
ya know New York is working hard on that
we have you can just abort a baby
whenever you want it could be 35 years
old well yeah we have the Freedom Tower
was lit up pink the day we decided you
could have an abortion at nine months
right
Cuomo the Catholic school educated
governor said yay pink power we can kill
babies now they can't do that in Jersey
unfortunately so they have to go to
veganism but we get to get to kill kids
at random I know I know who was it that
died and they didn't have the flag at
half-mast Barack Obama I don't know oh
it was somebody I remember that I don't
know killing 41 cult babies is
definitely at full mast look gas is
natural it's a very natural thing from
these animals so that's fine right but
vegans I've never seen healthy vegans
I'm not I'm not kidding so pedestrian so
I know some healthy vegan though I don't
Mike Mahler it's not quality he's very
healthy healthy when you see him no I
follows Instagram and I think you're
lying
there's a lot of unhealthy non vegans
when you go to Walmart course yes I'm
sure the people of walmart please don't
get me thinking of that song again or
the studio you find a lot of unhealthy
not here's something that's pretty
troubling a mother in the UK was
arrested after dead naming a [ __ ] on
Twitter dead naming by the way means
misgendering but that's the term now
dead naming so they make it sound more
sinister that's like killing a nine
months old pro-choice oh you mean I used
the scientifically proper pronoun dead
name it's like calling Bruce Jenner
that's dead naming if you said he comes
from a Daily Mail anyway so it's a silly
place claiming harassment and malicious
communications police arrested her this
mom in front of her children and they
held her for seven hours I mean fair to
the police they did find these friendly
refugees to babysit so it wasn't all of
that this is the country by the way that
probably sacrificed more than almost
anybody during World War two
to make sure that we fought the exact
forces that are taking them over and now
I literally 1984 all over again
I mean the book is becoming true reality
and we can watch it this sucks
they call it dead naming and they go
you've killed me by getting my gender
wrong and then you look at the person
you go you look like my dad with a girl
drawn on your face
yes let's be honest there was a 42%
chance you're gonna do it anyway yeah
I'm not happy about it out I'm only
happy that I've won this exchange right
now finally let's move on because this
is definitely doing come on D
platforming but Kamala Harris cuz we
love her we're gonna do everything wrong
with Kamala Harris next week by the way
every single Democratic candidate we're
going to do a they call it dive in now
on all of these candidates every single
one come on Harris is up next she
claimed that she used to get high in
high school yeah or so I was a college
college in college while she was
listening to Snoop Dogg in Tupac reason
pointed this out here's the problem
Harris graduated from college in law
school in the late eighties snute intact
didn't actually debut until the early
90s then you were mentioning this to
earlier that Tupac at this point was in
New Orleans Tupac was a very effeminate
drama club kid in New Orleans and he was
really big into dance he loved to dance
dance dad yeah he did was he had Ward
calm with a Doberman I see no changes
clang clang clang went the trolley
yes and then he did juice and he played
a thug and people went you know what I
could've like the thug guy mm-hmm it's
like okay from now on I'm a gangster he
basically just took the role and played
it out yeah it was a drama club kid till
he was in mean streets and he's like no
I'm a tough guy yeah yeah yeah that's
all the superheroes as well oh really do
you think actors take steroids
well imagine all of your drama club
nerds and make them Superman so some
people say that she was caught in a lie
by the way just trying to paint her to
the urban audience that others believe
she might have been confused with one of
the spec scripts to which she's recently
been attached actually as
regarding time travel which brings us to
this week seven plus one this week seven
plus always forget the one in the
chamber by look at this wonderful
Walther PPK beautiful it feels good it's
well that was one yesterday I think but
this is a beautiful firearm and it's
back being made by Walter again it's not
being licensed that's pretty cool too
those hacks at Smith & Wesson so this
week seven plus one is upcoming
time-traveling film project starting
Kamala Harris yeah so that's apparently
no snooping thank you so number seven
Back to the Future flyer yes that's one
that seems to be Gavin you wanna can you
it's right in front of you in case you
want to take number six oh I like number
six I've actually seen it it's Kamala
and Ted's bogus pandering boy adventure
yeah there we go
were you running out of breath you
sounded like the killer and minehunters
I had a pube in my throat okay number
five totally inaccurate recall that's
yeah one that seems to be that goes
right into it let's just keep that up
there number four terminator too bad
Judgment Day I wasn't super proud of it
judge but it made it in there let's go
to you you can do number three though I
like to x-men Future Passed yes check it
out and then you were a fan of number
two as well a hot tub lie machine is a
hot tub lie machine and by the way she
put on a stellar performance there as
the black guy from the office oh and the
number one Kamala Harris time-traveling
project the butter lye effect yeah and
of course the plus one is time this has
been this one of these look down here
because we did we were going to give out
an award to a trivia winner really but
they actually got the trivia wrong yeah
so they were wrong it was crazy beats
abortion Emporium it was abortion I
don't know what it was crazy beat
abortion garden that's roarin I don't
even know they called it Emporium it was
a stem cell Emporium which was a
different they were mixing different
areas of crazy Pete somebody out there
got real close the winner though is
William J Boston at will boss 88 show
him you love him who correctly answered
that Clint Howard played YouTube CEO
Susan Wojcicki
very nice you got that right I didn't
know what it was a really bad ghost
oh no the hats back the hands back did
he put it back oh that should get Clint
Howard he's awesome we wanted him live
always play Susan Wojcicki just because
we know how mad she was when she liked
me hotter than that if everyone around
her is going about Clint Howard if you
had him on your show no he's what you
would expect Clint Howard to be here he
was even our show from his hot tub naked
one time he drops his phone and we see
just a little bit of that kind of fold
above the the pecker and it goes right
into the water like it was a sketch but
this actually happened he calls back
guys I'm really sorry I'm using my iPad
now and he's in this cringe terrycloth
robe I did it rode his iPhone and he is
here's the one thing I will say about
Clint Halloran it's completely unrelated
he was there I thought oh my gosh when
he was doing Susan Wojcicki
maybe we should tell this after the show
because I focuses inside baseball the
people should you know join my club if
they want to actually but he took so
many takes like now am I am I saying
don't be such Evan easer to Evan ease
your youtube when I saying like don't be
such a I need you like 50 takes I was
going this is gonna be terrible and then
when we watched the rushes we were going
this guy is unbelievable he knows
exactly how he appears on camera where
his body moves through space every
single take was gold but this is 90
percent of the joke that he's remarkably
unattractive some would say like Steve
the city he's a good friend of the show
there I'm going to go but I don't think
he thinks he's hot no I think you're
correct he played a monster in a film
one time he played the bag and they just
like they tossed on an eye patch
prosthetics I feels good no no you think
a catalogue of 300 films all right okay
so the diamond same here again the
question the day what do you think about
social media if they need to be
regulated as public utilities Nigel
Faraj said that last time he was on
Jordan Peterson said that this brings us
to the topic right now Jack Dorsey of
course has been appearing all across new
media I don't know I don't think we
should call it new meat anymore just
media media typically podcast Joe Rogan
Sam Harris to talk about the company's
policies as well as free speech so the
problem here is that Dorsey
continual in my opinion deceives people
about Twitter's real policies while
dodging questions and in criticism I
think a couple things that are important
Jack Dorsey says that he doesn't want
echo that's what he says it doesn't want
echo chambers but it's important to
delineate the difference between I agree
I think all of us would agree the
targeted harassment targeted libel
something that could result in daxing
physical harm that has no role on social
me because it's a crime in real life by
the way but that's not the same as an
echo chamber and watch him talk about
echo chambers here on that I think this
is Joe Rogan yeah yeah we do incentivize
a lot of echo chambers because we don't
make it easy for people to sound that
you saying Impa sack but follows sounds
slightly complex okay so we feel shame
if I followed a bunch of accounts that
like like Boris Johnson who was
constantly giving me information about
reasons to leave tell my brakes it yeah
I would probably only see that
perspective nigel Faraj just will not
follow accounts that have a completely
different perspective or hopefully
generalize to but most people won't do
that well yeah no I think you're right
in here you can kind of see the solution
there where it's about he was looking at
like why is gear doing this just so I
know how short that is very it's because
you can't see outside the brim of your
hat notice the solution here's always to
try an engineer people's like when
people don't follow people with opposing
viewpoints probably we always encourage
you to we always encourage you to read
Huffington Post and Salon and go watch
Fox every single day we tell you to go
read the green new deal for yourself so
if people make the mistake of not doing
that that's on them but I find it really
interesting that he brings up brexit and
he mentions that as an echo chamber
here's what here's what he's missing all
of the mainstream media BBC and everyone
here in the states all of the news
outlets promoted and he brags that
propaganda
yeah it's by the way they were so
surprised when pregs it happened because
they believe their own lives and because
Twitter and new media was designed to be
an alternative platform what you are
seeing are alternatives alternative
points of view that's what I think
people are missing here Boris Johnson is
not more powerful in the BBC nor is
Nigel Faraj but you get him on Twitter
and people are actually able to hear his
ideas they say well that's a little bit
interesting I didn't know that because
before this hat we do have diversity of
ideas here you you
people to be able to hear the other side
basically what he's saying is not that I
don't want diversity of ideas he's like
I just don't want the ideas I disagree
with he's more serious there yet but
we'll get but that's his point
what's with the hypocrisy of that
statement though he's sitting there
saying people get into a bubble and they
don't look up to it other views
meanwhile hey you want a different view
why don't you go look up Gavin McInnes
on Twitter or Owen Benjamin on Twitter
or Alex Jones on Twitter
so he's censoring people creating a
bubble and then saying there's this
problem where people just get in a
bubble there's real lazy that's a really
good if you're the one your whole thing
is a bubble now dude yeah that's a good
point really quick like um just recently
hit the bell you don't don't not take
your breath before I go to you now
I want to say something I'm okay get
recently YouTube tweeted out Oh wouldn't
it be horrible imagine if you couldn't
watch the videos you love what from
YouTube that would be terrible
yeah what if they were demonetized yeah
what if people who were subscribed to
your videos weren't able to find them I
don't know what and here's what's great
Lee you know Leptis echo chambers are
fine right wing echo chambers become
hate speech and now we just let's just
not have right wing echo chambers at all
let's just get rid of all of the people
by the way defend Gavin calm so you can
go and help him with his fight yes PLC
nume everyone was so excited about it
when it started I remember talking about
this in - three years ago when this was
a once a week three-hour show everyone
was singling there's no barrier entry
now I said watch when you see some
conservatives when you see alternative
viewpoints doing well the Sharks are
going to come yeah you're going to see
them particularly from old media ABC NBC
CBS Viacom ray Siena Trey Turner you're
going to see them go after YouTube where
they cannot win on a level playing field
as it relates to viewers as a relates to
content so how do they win money and
censoring the opposition and here we are
now this was the whole purpose to new
media what so that someone like a Boris
Johnson or Nigel thrush could have just
as loud of a voice as the BBC yeah Kevin
we should make it clear - there is such
a thing as Nazis there is a tiny group
of Pepe nutbars who Photoshop you and I
with swastikas and gas chambers and they
talk about the JQ and the 14 words in
the
and all their little jargon stuff and if
you allow those guys into your platform
it tends to be pretty bad for your
platform they tend to just make everyone
go I'm getting out of here right there's
sort of like the gremlins we're talking
about the other day but on the other
side but that's it's letting a bunch of
guys crap in the parking lot where
everyone's tailgating exactly no one
else wants to be there right but those
those tailgate crappers are a very tiny
sliver and they're very easy to identify
right and I think Twitter started out
doing a pretty good job of getting rid
of that tiny minority of lunatic Nazis
maybe like 1% of the population or much
less than half a percent and then they
they were normal for a while and
comedians could tell horrible jokes and
iron out content and it's pretty fun and
then using the justification of the
sliver the tailgate crappers they
started just getting anyone Christian
conservative remotely controversial and
now it's kind of the opposite by the way
the only people I know that use the term
nutbar are you and kevin O'Leary you
know you're sounding like some kind of a
left wing nut bar I'm out he's
conservative good like hey he's Canadian
conservative like yes and I don't think
you need a gun clip with more than five
bullets what do you want in his
interview with Dorsey actually Sam
Harris who I would actually I would love
to have Sam Harris in the show but I do
find listening to his show sometimes
painful yeah they can be very dull but
it doesn't mean it's not a good show I
just have to watch it sometimes is that
a necessity
Sam Harris pointed out that a liberal
feminist by the way was banned for
saying that men aren't women here you go
Megan Murphy just feminists but she's
not sufficiently woke apparently on the
on the transgender topic and she she
wrote a tweet which I believe red men
are not women and got suspended over
that tweet you'd suspend it right away
and not to tell my own substrate when
there was a clear concerted campaign led
by less you mentioned white supremacist
websites and of course their acquiescent
liberals on social media to defame and
paint me as a neo-nazi with fake tweets
like gasps the Jews hanging the n-words
Twitter by the way took no action you
have those falls on libelous tweets
removed that's important that's they
said it to repeat it this is what it's
like the timeline with the FAQ from
quartet yeah said
has the wrong one you answer questions
all day I made a mistake all day long
okay what do you want googly googly eye
she could fit right in and in like a
trash can come out like I'm trying to
sleep in here well look if you're gonna
talk about echo chambers a Silicon
Valley echo chamber long sigh let's
bring up Matt too cute man you bring up
the overlay here the memes some of them
and remain up today by the way yeah
repeated then targeted libelous tweets
try to destroy the ability for anyone
here to make a living
didn't violate Twitter's policies huh
and by the way also tried to docks me
just didn't work and they're still up
today go ahead yeah well no I I was
gonna kind of mention that too like I
understand if somebody wants to post
something like that like he said that
little sliver that's gonna post
something as soon as you bring it up it
should be taken care of that would be a
level playing field right hey sorry
that's true you're not that guy we're
gonna pull it down right but they live
in the Silicon Valley echo chamber
that's their echo chamber like well I
don't want this points like I don't
wanna Briggs it we echo chamber or what
do you think mark and Sue's yes
understand that when they call this
white nationalist white nationalist get
pissed on this race thing I hate that
he's always cooking for shekels
race-mixing Jew lover who hangs out with
gays I don't like that guy and it's sort
of like 9/11 to where they goes 9/11 was
an inside job in the Turks Co we busted
our ass on that attack right take her
down the twin towers Martin Sheen is
sitting there like I am pretty sure was
with Dick Cheney Dick Cheney what's with
some bird shots it's plants especially
friend that Jack in that interview Jack
Dorsey he mentions journalists you
specifies the importance of journalists
since Twitter goes out of its way to
ensure that the hyper sensitive leftist
journalists don't receive any criticism
at all know people who jokingly tweeted
learn to code at the journalists were
suspended immediately
record time learn to code journalist
that was the funniest thing that I had
seen I was just like this is perfect
there's they're banning people for
saying this and that's what they said
when it was what the Virginia call you
know something like banning people for
acerbic wit now swear words in that
very succinct and mean things like if
computers existed back in the time of
Jack Benny he'd be like learn to code
it's also good advice you know they'd
have better job security if they knew
how to code please we would love to have
you on this program of course we would
be fair is it about preventing
right-wing ideas and/or science from
spreading or is it about echo chambers
let us know
I think another point that people really
need to at least it needs to be
illuminated is the reasons for the bans
yeah because Dorsey's been going around
and I want to know also by the way
another question how do you think the
interviewers have treated him I've heard
a lot of people complain saying that
they thought he wasn't pressed enough by
some of these podcasts and then some
people say that they think it's
productive if he's in any podcast at all
I don't know I think it's productive if
he's in a podcast but not if he
repeatedly lies and then switches yeah I
said just kidding I had my fingers
crossed which we'll get to in a little
bit paranoid in fact Jack Benny here
nobody's calling him on it I mean it's
kind of hard to call out the guy who is
the gatekeeper essentially right that's
dumb but it's hard to call out people
unless you're sixty minutes you're so
happy to get a huge guest like that I
got to be honest by Jack Dorsey I would
spend the interview kissing his ass
really yes probably physically you've
seen this video of Gavin kissing
someone's asking a million place but if
you own a Photoshop pen please we're so
many obese these days and we're so bad
at conflict that when you get a good
guest and you hammer them you have a
back-and-forth
you'll never get a liberal again you'll
never get a famous person again
right so you have to sort of it's like
feeding a squirrel you have to be like
thanks for coming on the show Jack okay
you do your propaganda and then I'll
maybe cast aspersions after you leave
[Laughter]
important for the kind of segues into
the fact that Dorsey repeatedly said
that Twitter should have been more clear
about why people were banned what the
terms of service best but here he is
explaining it I realize that we're
probably gonna make some mistakes along
the way and all we can do that beard
corrects and that is just be open about
where we are that's probably where we
failed you most in the past is we just
haven't been open about is what led to
particular decisions how
or Terms of Service of this is the go-to
whenever someone gets bandits well if
you read the Terms of Service you know
why you were banned but then if you ask
them how a specific person violated the
terms of service they refused to give an
answer watch Torcy do it right here I'm
not I'm not sure what the what the
actual like you know violations were but
we have we have a set number of actions
making on Murphy what I was banned it's
that we read the man or not with the
case you brought up I'm not sure what's
behind the megan murphy men are not
women when i was banned it said you've
been permanently suspended for semicolon
space what do you mean what does that
mean two reasons either hoots you it
doesn't matter what the term is served
by the way him and Sam are like the two
most monotone like low-key guys it's not
a sketch with men and there's no punch
yeah they speak they speak like cat
burglar what like big cars he can come
stairs just the jewelry's probably there
in the master of yeah
like cat burger then Carson wouldn't get
talked over on that show boring hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
on YouTube because apparently
subscriptions don't mean anything joined
mug clips ago to the Daily Show a lot of
credit a calm slash mug Club subscribe
on iTunes for the audio version of
course rate it and by the way big for
our Oscars lives on February 24th
torture at 8 p.m. Eastern drinking game
the rules they posted no the whole point
is we watch it so you guys don't have to
and I think Gavin might be at least
making an appearance yeah oh Jesus I'm
gonna be at the US because I was invited
I'm gonna be in the front row with
sitting with a woman named Penelope
millions really yeah is an actual thing
yeah she rescued a Harvey Weinstein's
daughter from a fire and I'm gonna be
there for the Oscar for worst liar okay
I don't know what he's telling he's
telling you that it's a joke no I knew
that part yeah I figured it out at the
end there was no fire it was just
Weinstein trying to rape I'm just
hearing those words come out of my mouth
going well that that's what's going on
lying is incredibly easy as seen by Jack
Dorsey here's the thing the only thing
that Jack has been consistent about is
stressing that harassment campaigns are
the most babble offense and I think we
all agree with that here yeah but we've
already said that those campaigns don't
apply to targeted repeated libel of
someone like myself or Gavin by the way
or a more recent example they're coming
to school kids yeah celebrities were
calling for the kids addresses yeah
wanting them to be harmed because a kid
smiled at a toothless meth head who was
twice deferred sorry twice when a wall
as a veteran was a refrigerator
repairman and was wearing a Mogga hat
yeah they called for school shootings
they said it would be a great school to
shoot up and you know what the right
doesn't do that like how many times have
Dana lash had to move we can't show
pictures of our kids you look at Chris
Hayes and Mark Ruffalo they're all like
here's our kids right yeah I don't even
say my kids names right because other
kids
I mean look [ __ ] let's be honest
they all look that he hasn't focused
we're gonna see that the glad a guy who
would call you up for that he will
what's happening absolute you and I
don't even know what your kids look like
but if they look like you they haven't
focused enough from what he said Dorsey
on the off-site ramifications of Twitter
here's a clip focused on enough we
haven't focused on the f off platform
ramifications of what happens online so
basically I don't even need that clip
because I told you you're right check
Dorsey you haven't because you've been
more worried about journalists receiving
slightly mean tweets or people making
scientifically accurate claims it might
offend I don't know point 5 percent of
the population by the way you missed
Isis recruiting bomb threats and tufa
staging violent assaults on people
because you were more worried about a
BuzzFeed boldly getting her feelings
hurt over a doctor putting on her BMI of
76 ok this is what's been happening good
we really focus on the offset
ramifications do you mean like daxing
kids from a school with a maggot
that's and murky territory I'm gonna I'm
gonna seek my wise counsel Zuckerberg
what somebody and Cortez probably has
private meetings them I think another
point obviously is uh that people need
to to see here certain segments of these
interviews Jack actually kind of lets
the mask slip and the good thing is we
get to see kinda like with the abortion
laws we now get to see the true agenda
of Twitter where I want Twitter
specifically to go is I you know I I
think it's existential right now that we
we we have global conversations about
some things that will become crisis
climate change being one of them whose
no one that's going to solve that
problem alone economic disparities rise
of AI and job displacement and just like
us all floating decisions to the
American really puts the world at a
disadvantage because it incentivizes
more of the echo chambers which lead to
things like nationalism instead of
taking the broader picture no simply you
could write a clickbait headlines
radical
globalist Jack Dorsey now pushing anti
human green New Deal agenda and it would
be accurate yeah wouldn't be clickbait
that's what do you say and it's
basically just propaganda that he's
quoting it's like guys there is a big
debate on climate science right now if
it's changing as much as you say and if
we are the people that are actually
causing it or if it's the cows farting
according to AOC right it's not science
actually I think what's important is
this in this final clip some here Sam
Harris got Jack Dorsey to admit that
there they're no longer trying to be
neutral here you saying I I don't
believe that we can afford to take a
neutral stance don't finally I think we
should optimize for neutrality viscid
you believe that we should optimize for
impartiality and I do think there's a to
me a neutral neutrality there's a lot
more passive a lot more hands-off
I don't think we can just be be this
neutral passive platform
let's just cancel the connecting himself
he is we don't want to hang neutral but
we want to be unfair
he's hoping everybody will be asleep we
want to ensure that fairness plays no
role on our platform I'm sure he knows
what he's talking about
did you do an interview with Joe Rogan
for four hours and so I don't know what
that's what the violation was and it's
really important that we have freedom of
speech and then you go on here you say
yeah I don't remember the I don't be the
time on which shows he did but you would
go on shows for hours and say yeah yeah
we want it to be an open platform for
all and then he's like now we don't we
like over Sonia Sotomayor Supreme Court
judge - yes I should be a Supreme Court
judge I'm I'm totally impartial I'm
gonna be a great judge then she gets
when she goes I will we would be lying
if we didn't say that our background and
our Hispanic heritage didn't affect our
decisions your job as a judge it should
not be a Hispanic woman right you'd be
just a an impartial you know judge
justice is blind and then you have Jack
Dorsey going we are totally neutral here
we're just gonna be impartial let
everyone make their own decisions and we
obviously can't be neutral about that
when we do that it'll be with the left
wing been right what do you think we'll
just get Helen Thomas the Jewish to
Poland what are you talking about why
are you here basically I think they just
got scared
Trump won and brags it happened they're
like what the hell's going on okay can
we be roll anymore it can't happen
no and they won by the way just because
people getting a message out there of
truth yes that once brexit this idea
that it was a lot a good example you
know what a lie is that some kid
harassed a Native American toothless
meth head who was twice deferred sorry I
went AWOL refrigerator repairman in
Vietnam because it amarga hat that is a
lie not the therapist to being an
autonomous nation this is this is a
great example of what we've been talking
about all week the left fears
transparency they run from it they check
under their bed for it so it's a good
indicator if someone tries to shut down
transparency that they're a leftist or a
liar but I repeat myself and that's what
we're seeing with Jack it's not just a
Cascio cortes with this this this is
this is in your deal no us no it's not
but you wrote it I updated the wrong
copy
I know nothing this is Jack this is what
Jack is doing well hold on a second what
are you what's going on well really we
should be more clear about our policies
well what are your policies I don't
really want to talk about that right
well what do you think the Polish eats
it's in Iran well I should Center on
being neutral okay so how are you gonna
be neutral we don't want to be neutral
do I need to shoot myself because I
don't my spots are into trouble if you
want to know what Silicon Valley is just
picture Bernie Cory Booker
Acacio car Ted sitting in a boardroom
deciding what can and cannot be said on
the Internet that's what Silicon Valley
is the politicians the far-left
politicians I should say are just like
the Silicon Valley tech executives they
use nice words like transparency truth
safety but whenever you ask some
questions they run for cover you so the
same thing when Zuckerberg yeah when he
had to testify when you saw the same
thing with widgets key remember back
then she's like wow I think it's
important that we have a neutral well
how you gonna do that well but we don't
want hate speech what's hate speech when
you start shining a light on these guys
they scurry back into the darkness
that's why there's no accountability
when we explain where we line up here on
every issue what we're really quick okay
Jack
what are trying to attack you we just
want to put all the cards in the table
that's all we're asking for you let's
not even go to the public utilities
today but we just we've all agree we all
agree we talked about this yesterday we
you have to be honest about your
business practices you can't say we
weren't clear about the Terms of Service
and then we said well what are the terms
of services and you know I don't know I
don't even know honey that's not what it
can be we just want to know where
everyone stands on these platforms but
instead they flip over the table and
they throw the cards away that's what
Silicon Valley is Acacio Cortez come out
now I'm doing it affected Acacio Cortez
no not you o kzo Cortez II I just want
to say Camila hairs / Cory Booker in a
boardroom that's what it is and now that
you know you just have to play by their
rules or get kicked off the platform hey
social media let freedom ring defend
Gavin calm by the way defend Gavin come
we back with Lorne southern after this
defend Gavin
[Music]
okay frankly it will be erected nice it
big huge I want this to be clear okay
it'll be fantastic log pick hard so much
winning you won't know what to do
frankly with all the winning wall side
effects may include reduced crime
increased wages economic productivity
drastically reduced sex trafficking and
women not for use by those who can
understand its commercial pepper from
Super Lawyer those Aztec Mayan and/or
Incan heritage wall ask your health care
professional about wall today dad for
Mexicans this is been a really one-sided
excuse the pun mugging since the opening
bell when the tumblr inspected the
entire first throw with a
[Applause]
the referee really needs to put a stop
what is the mug looking for now is that
a flaming chair
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you have anything to say to YouTube the
current champion of the world D platform
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
where your pockets are
I understand wondering what's in your
pocket yeah not where your pockets are I
mean if you're an M&M seems to me you're
high if you're maybe if you were Eminem
circa that was it cocaine was a heroin I
don't know he did something I just want
an excuse to show off actually barbell
sent me these new these new chinos which
I don't usually wear I always wear jeans
or never sponsored the show but man they
are comfortable for a guy like me with a
giant fat ass our next guest does not
have a giant fat ass
she's very spelt people like her you can
follow her on the Twitter at Lauren
underscore southern her website is
Lauren southern dotnet just search her
on YouTube and you will find her she
hasn't been banned yet her documentary
borderless and actually has a new
trailer out this week I believe now you
know who it is Lauren southern thank you
for being here thank you for having me
so there's so much so we were just
talking during the break and you said so
much has happened it's kind of tough to
pick a moment but I know you've been
making the rounds for your speech that
you gave at the EU recently changing my
mind on immigration is what it was
called first off how much of this was
actually given as a speech in front of
people versus you know like the the
green-screen portion right so I did the
speech in front of about 50 MEP s of
course when you're at the EU it's not
necessarily about having a full room as
much as it is about who is in the room
who is affecting governments and
policies but we did actually refilm the
speech because the technology that they
use for recording EU events is subpar
like anything that government does right
logitech that's usually how it works
yes the audio is a bit bad but we read
it at everything that I said in the
speech and my YouTube video was exactly
what I said to these politicians and I
think it came across quite well because
a lot of these politicians
I think throw away right-wing arguments
is just oh they're hateful they're
racist but the speech I gave if people
have watched it was actually on
completely from the immigrants
perspective and that's what a lot of
borderless is I'd say about 70% of the
documentary is us just with the migrants
on the ground talking to them asking
them about their experiences what it's
been like and something that I was so
shocked to find on this trip was once we
got to the European part of the
documentary actually with these migrants
once they've made it
we had a large amount of them telling us
they wish they had never left home and
they wished they could go back that's
something that I'd never seen that is
like they'd really rather go back to you
know Syria where they're being burned
alive in cages versus maybe a little
lack of gratitude I mean I'm not saying
the UK is that great but it still seems
better than Syria at this point well
this is the issue is I probably only met
about ten Syrians if that during the
entire trip I thought there were seven
Christians my world is topsy-turvy now
Laura educate me please it was very
confusing yes the majority of people
coming right now so we actually spent
time on the Turkish side of the border
waiting along the coast where it's just
covered in just mess clothing everywhere
dinghies vests like the evidence of the
migration is insane and we spent time
like hiding from Jean Dharma helicopters
above us so the Turkish police under
trees with all of these migrants and
every single one of them with us they're
waiting for the boats to come to take
them to Greece was from Afghanistan once
we got to the Greek side most of the
people in the camps were from I mean
like I said I met about ten people from
Syria right the majority of them were
from other places in the Middle East
certainly Morocco also here in Africa I
would think that still London would be
nicer than most of Afghanistan guide but
I don't know well here's the issue is
because they don't want to be deported
human traffickers will tell them throw
your passport out burn your passport so
they get to Europe they have no ID they
don't really want to be identified
because they're not actually refugees a
lot of them or maybe they have criminal
backgrounds so they can't really apply
for asylum they can't really get jobs or
work think about how long it takes to
get an actual immigrant visa it can take
like five six years so imagine how much
longer it takes for people who have
burnt their passports have no ID and
have no I waited way of proving who they
are where they've come from so they just
end up living under bridges they
effectively can't do anything they can't
live anywhere they can't buy a house
they can't work and they're sitting
there thinking why did Angler Merkel
tell us
refugees welcome why did the media tell
us we should all come here why are these
traffickers promising us paradise why am
i living under a bridge where so that
they're blaming this on the right-wing
trolls on twitter but their policies are
creating actual bridge trolls yes
effectively and that's the thing a lot
of these liberals think that compassion
is just a one-time thing they show up
with these crocheted blankets these
refugees welcome signs they change their
profile picture to say hashtag refugees
welcome but where are they when these
people are starving under bridges where
are they when these people are
completely packed in camps and can't be
processed it would have been so much
better to just be honest with them and
tell them you know what the European
dream is a dream still for the European
people we've got lots of problems you're
probably not going to be processed for a
while if you're not a refugee there's a
good chance you're never going to be
able to live anywhere or get a job or be
processed if we were just honest with
these people a lot of these issues a lot
of this issue with migration in human
trafficking could be solved and even
better we would have more money and
resources to help legitimate refugees I
think if we weren't inviting the world
right and I think it's a very important
point that you make and I do want to say
I want to say I know there was a man
named I think Mohammed who asked you a
question who talked about how he was
concerned that this would be another
right wing hit piece and how I wouldn't
here's the thing I wouldn't say
even-handed I know that you're more
concerned I think people watching know
that you're more conservative but you
can have a personal bias and also try to
look at an issue through a point of view
accurately and for people who don't know
it does seem that you've made an earnest
effort to look at this from the
immigrants from the migrants from the
refugee from the asylum seekers whatever
term you want to use that day okay don't
want to be I don't want to be hooked on
this with this with this project and I
did want to ask you because you said to
this person he said well thank you for
noticing I have kind of transitioned
from the kind of shocking in-your-face
trolling journalism until what I'm doing
now I will say this I've noticed that
and I'm impressed by it why what was the
catalyst for that well I think that
there was a place for the shocking
conversations just saying like feminism
is cancer just to get yourselves out
there because there was no real right
conversation going on before Trump era
for the anti-feminist stuff for the anti
socialism stuff and we kind of needed to
just bring ourselves into the
conversation at all because we had been
completely excommunicated from the media
excommunicated from classroom
discussions and we just said well let's
shock them let's shock them to get
ourselves into the conversation now
we've kind of got a foot in the door in
popular culture young people are
watching conservative media more and
more you've got PewDiePie h3h3 all of
these big names finally talking about
how insane the left has become so there
was a place for it then but I think that
the shock stuff has had the effect that
it is going to have and convinced as
many people as it's going to convince
and now we need to get back to some
serious hard evidence statistics
long-form stuff there do you think
everyone has a different place there's
always going to be a place for that
shock stuff I still enjoy it I still
enjoy watching when people do it but
there's definitely an opening or vacuum
for people to make documentaries and
longer-form
conservative discussion because if we
just get into the troll style stuff then
it's conservatism and right-wing
ideology for young people isn't gonna be
taken too seriously and there are people
yearning for more than that right I
think it's a good point I guess my
question is is why did you since you say
there's a place for both and I agree
with you why did you feel personally led
to moving on to kind of this chapter
because it is it is different and it's
obviously I do think it's productive and
I agree with you there's a place for
both but you've decided that for
yourself this is what you want to do is
there a specific reason that you said
for me this is my priority now honestly
I I've never been a professor of
anything I'm not an expert I'm 23 years
old I'm not gonna pretend I know
everything so for the things that I do
know and the things that I could speak
on I have given my opinion yeah I've
said my thoughts on feminism I've said
my thoughts on immigration socialism
whatever it may be I've given my opinion
and I realized that the only way I could
continue doing YouTube is if I were just
repeating myself for the sake of having
YouTube career and I didn't want to do
that talking into a camera in a car
owning Libs isn't it funny that people
who claim they're intolerant are I go
there
name the tower there in town did you
know free speech is good right like I
said yeah I've made my point and if I
want to actually do something that I
feel is contributing and I don't feel
like I'm just doing for the sake of
having a career because this was never
when I started this was never about
making a career out of this I wasn't
getting paid to make videos initially it
wasn't a job for me right I just
actually believed in it so if I wanted
to still do something that I believed in
well I was gonna have to dive a little
deeper and go on the ground and because
I'm not an expert the thing that I can
offer is I can go on the ground and I'm
crazy enough to go and you actually see
these things for myself and bring back
to life but you're a little more mature
and a little more mature now and that
you bring security with you member last
time I spoke with you said Lauren don't
do this without serious security because
at one point we had some conversations
like now be fine I'm like no no listen
it's cute when you're young
once I became a husband I realized like
no no I'm not gonna do this and just run
the risk and we don't want to see you
get hurt
but you know I really appreciate you
saying that because what you're
basically talking about doing here well
if correct me if I'm wrong is learning
with the audience and learning hopefully
accurately and earnestly now picture
this you've never done any of this never
done any of the fundraising never worked
for any other company never worked a
real job in your life obviously you've
done all those things but picture if you
hadn't in you're a congresswoman
that's Cortez Cortez was in that phase
where she thought she knew everything
and she now runs up a portion of our
government that's what's scary so I hope
people tear a page from your book and
you know what that's a stressful thing
personally as well like I guarantee
Cortez wakes up and is aware of that at
times because if you keep up a facade of
knowing everything and pretending you
know everything and you don't that is
personally and mentally just really
really difficult cuz you'll you know
you'll never actually live up to that
standard so I wonder if Cortez wakes up
in the morning thinking damn I have to
put on this mask and keep this act up
right I can't make enough sex on the
beaches my bartending school didn't help
me at all I don't know how to balance a
budget unless it's a lime wedge and
someone's navel cavity let me ask you
this say we have more resources going
back to borderless there's a transition
you see we have more resources to fix
this this problem do you offer a
solution or do you have some ideas as to
how we could solve the problem because I
know everyone thinks there
but like you said once the dust settles
those compassionate people and we're all
compassion I mean the compassionate left
us disappear how do you think we could
handle us in a way that would be
even-handed or effective or best use of
funds the the thing I am becoming
increasingly more aware of is that there
are no solutions there are only
trade-offs there are better options than
others but in this case I would say it
is the most compassionate thing to
everyone involved to be honest about
what is going on because right now the
only people that are benefiting from us
telling migrants come to Europe you've
got a place here open borders look at
all these migrants there they're playing
on the Olympic teams they're going to
the Vatican with the Pope there shaking
Merkel's hands there shaking Trudeau's
hand look at the life they get to live
and then that's not reality the only
people who benefit from that are human
traffickers right like I hope I think of
an industry is that by the way I know
you've talked about this yeah so when we
were in Morocco we we spoke to people
about how much it costs it costs about
2,000 euros a thousand to 2,000 euros
across the small areas to the Greek
islands and then from Morocco it's 2,000
to 5,000 euros and they're shot being
like 50 people on one of these boats and
they're sending out tons of boats every
single day so think about how much money
these people are making per month
they're making millions millions and
millions and millions of dollars through
this so of course they love the media
they love when they say refugees welcome
they love when they say come here and as
soon as you touch European land in the
Schengen zone you can shop around for
your your welfare country of your choice
yeah and when you talk to these people
in the mountains of Morocco they
genuinely believe they're like when I
get to London I'm gonna be a rapper I'm
gonna be a football star I'm gonna be
this that in the other they actually
believe Europeans live in a paradise or
people in the Western world live in a
paradise because that's what they see on
the internet right they don't yeah and
of course the traffickers are gonna tell
them that as well they aren't told the
truth so is any realism issues because
like you said a lot of them they're
burning their passports their
identification because these traffickers
are telling them so how do we reach
those people before
traffickers how do you think people can
most effectively cut that off at the
pass well one big issue is you've got
these NGOs that are out patrolling the
waters and picking up these people and
bringing them into Europe so that's
their first indication that of course
we're welcome
Europeans have sent out boats to come
and pick us up and bring us into Europe
right of course they want us there and
then of course once those NGOs let them
go into Europe they're completely on
their own and they have nowhere to be
and of course they're gonna become
criminals and do horrible things because
they have no identity no job nothing to
do so if we shut down these NGOs you
will see the biggest route into Europe
used to be the Libyan the biggest one
has been the Greece route but Libya to
Italy was one of the largest ones as
well now it's almost completely shut
down the first two months of this year
only 50 people have come from Libya to
Italy because the Italians shut down
their ports to these non-government
organisation ships picking people up of
course the drownings have also
completely stopped from Libya to Italy
because people are no longer taking a
reckless journey when they know they're
not going to be welcomed yeah so you've
stopped people from drowning you've
stopped people from living under bridges
you've stopped people for you stopped a
giant human trafficking ring that are
genuinely also enslaving people and
using people as mules for drugs and
weapons yeah into Europe so I'd say if
you shut down a lot of these NGO boats
and the incentives to come that's a good
start and I would imagine there are
several other solutions and trade offs
at least offered in the film borderless
people can see that trailer on your
YouTube channel this week you know it's
not all too dissimilar for what's
happening here in the southern border in
the United States I don't know if you
watch the State of the Union address but
when President Trump mentioned the sex
trafficking all the women who were
wearing white for women's rights you
know Cortes said that she was sitting
until she looked and everyone was
standing up clapping like I guess I
don't hate Donald Trump that much I'll
get up but won't clap for being anti sex
trafficking when you're wearing white
for women's rights we should all be on
board with with if nothing else if
you're even the biggest libertarian on
the planet where you think heroin should
be legal great you still probably have
to be against sex trafficking against
one's will because not even well in
prostitution and Cortes and I don't know
who else wearing white they would
it was the Bee Gees album they didn't
stand up all right Lauren where's the
best place for people to find you and
see more info on this documentary
everything will be posted on my twitter
at Lauren underscore southern and there
will be a new trailer up this week so
stay tuned there all right trailer not a
teaser that means it's more subs now
this one is a proper trailer it's lots
of meat to it this is a proper trailer
and Lauren southern net hopefully Jack
Dorsey doesn't ban you Lauren thank you
so much
hello lollie with here don't forget the
pike hi - in the SoundCloud I wrote it
hey your loser
[Music]
then melting here little Rosa part of
story Clara considerations told you to
tune into the water with Crowder
afterlife spray departed on February
24th no no no that's a Sunday there's
gotta be a for our lives for you better
tone em you got less sort of them go
godless
hey one live root of the week right now
in Gavin still he has the Hat on
properly is it more comfortable I put my
hat back on it's much more comfortable
without the headphones yeah it's kind of
like you're going for the Beastie Boys
had sex with hell or high water right
now I was kind of going for Hunter s
Thompson never learned to read all right
we have to get to our sponsor Walther
firearms you were just coming in how
nice this firearm is now how good it
feels I think it feels great yeah I felt
a lot of guns it's got a real gravitas
to it well once you get your permit
there in New York well we'll have Walter
send you what they can it's different
from state to state their sponsor the
show and they're by the way there are a
lot of great firearms out there we
talked about this you know clock HK of
course there are great firearms at the
certain points like do I want a BMW do
on a Mercedes all we ask is that you try
the Walther try it I've never met anyone
who's tried a Walther firearm compared
it to you know what was in that same
kind of price range and not preferred it
and if you don't like it that's fine but
they do have the balls to step up and
support this show that's Walter firearms
and of course you can join a lot of
credit that come slash my club that's
what keeps us going Walter thank you so
much for really happy that our studios
are protected by Walter
[Music]
[Music]
couple of things that's the last time I
let John Johnny boy clean my pipes you
put in the stem upside down so it makes
a horrible snorkel
oh yeah we're not working right now and
you see look these are curves this way
see all right dad mm-hmm CREB it the
opposite way it is the Drowned again so
it is the drowning dance I don't know
when that started exactly also defend
Gavin calm Thank You Gavin McInnes let
us know what you think how much you
enjoyed Gavin in third chair we have a
bunch people obviously who come in and
thirdly I think with Penn tell us next
week and tell us I think I think it's
next week I mean I don't know but coming
in so you know later we're gonna have
some some kind of more permanent people
we're just we're just trying and then
sometimes he will come in in third chair
we've had some big names or then get in
trouble and come back even though we
love them
there was something else that I was
going to say I can't go next week is a
big in camera video Tuesday potentially
I don't know you know we don't know what
footage exactly that we have cuz we
about four or five different hidden
cameras still going through but I know
what we do have at least on audio and
it's it's something that we didn't
expect that's a big video on Tuesday
we'll probably do a show Monday not
entirely sure and of course Wednesday
Thursday we're gonna have some new
change my mind is coming up I want to
kind of warn people before usually these
closing segments are are I guess
uplifting or helpful
it was branded by some fans crowd or
closes and so now we use that on YouTube
thank you for the idea but I want to
warn anyone there who is having a good
time I don't want to ruin your day this
one is a little bit sad hopefully
helpful so you know if you need to grab
some time or come back to this later 3 -
there you go spoiler alert um I know I
talked about this on social media this
week that hopper of course who you know
and hopper he's been on the show quite a
bit was diagnosed with cancer lymphoma
cancer so it's been a very hard week for
us it is you know listen here's the
thing I I've debated going I've gone
back and forth whether I should even
talk about this because we don't know he
could live a longer time you know he's a
10 year old dog and he may not depends
on how he responds to treatment depends
on how aggressive it is
and it was a real roller coaster ride
because we got this on Friday this news
and then we went to the oncologist and
they said hey we actually don't think
that's what it is and so we felt so good
like a weight was lifted and then we
found out yesterday that that is what it
was and they said maybe it's not the
fast-moving cancer and it is the
fast-moving
lymphoma cancer and I know is people
it's always a cop-out what people try to
talk about it I just want to talk about
things so people don't feel alone but I
do know what with millions of listeners
out there people are tuning and they're
probably people going through a similar
situation I want to be clear about
something here I know that a man for
whom the hardest thing they've ever
experienced is their dog with cancer has
lived a charmed life it's not lost on me
okay I want to make sure that I
understand that I'm not equivocating
losing a dog by the way he may not we
don't know what's gonna happen we don't
know how long he's going to be here but
I did feel that since he's been an
active part of the show that I owed it
to you to talk about this now and when
it does happen when we he's not with us
anyone we're not going to do another
clothing segment on this I wanted to
talk about this now so that you didn't
feel lied to because I know that Hopper
out there is twenty thirty thousand
followers on Twitter we don't even know
who runs an accountant by the way
whoever runs the hopper accounts out
there obviously when when the final
chapter is written and appreciate if you
just kind of close it down because I
don't don't want to have to to look at
that um so I understand that someone
who's been through something like this
saying it's the hardest thing that
they've they've been through they've
lived a very charmed life this has
absolutely been the hardest thing that
I've ever experienced and I try to be
honest as honest as I can with you these
last two years have been some of the
hardest in my life and this is the
hardest thing I've been through I've
lost relatives I've lost friends I've
had friends who were taken too young I
know this doesn't compare to to losing
children but my dad had melanoma and I
know it doesn't mean that I don't love
my father more it doesn't mean that I
understand the value of human life is
greater than a dog that's not it but
hopper is outside of my wife the living
being on this earth that I gave more of
myself too than any other person on this
planet
my best friend is docking and there's no
more honest way to express it um I don't
know I know this this is the kind of you
know what get I don't care someone will
take that and turn into a meme up see I
don't you know I'll walk away from this
before I ever actually have to feel
ashamed of the fact that I'm emotional
over the fit emotional over losing a
good friend and I know it'll be used
against me and know that'll turn into a
meme whatever and I've talked about this
I don't think that men need to not cry
it's they just don't think you need to
cry at every single thing that bothers
you I don't think you need to cry
because someone called you a name this
is when men often cry um let me kind of
give you some information on Harper
because you see him but you don't you
don't really know the whole story I
prayed I prayed for opera I really did
my whole life and he's really been a
gift in my life into my family's life
and he's been the best gift and I poured
so much myself
I never had a dog growing up and I
wanted one I begged that pleaded for one
I had all the dog books
I watched the dog shows on TV I knew
every breed I knew all of the training
methods but I couldn't have one because
I was raised in an apartment and by the
way this is gonna come back to something
that's hopefully helpful for people out
there so you don't just nishan it off
because it's sad there's a purpose to
this and I learned a lot this week not
that cheesy this dog taught me more
about it's almost like this dog was
rescuing me it's not that but I did
learn a lot this week I couldn't have a
talk when I grew up because I was raised
in an apartment little three-bedroom on
Reed Street in the South Shore of
Montreal you can run a search on that
right now and see the silver spoon with
which I was raised once I'd been married
for a couple of years I decided that I
was going to fulfill a dream and see at
this point in time I should clarify it
parted ways with Fox News I'd sold some
script rights I was getting burnt out
with stand-up I was in Western Michigan
kind of floundering I was depressed I
talked I'm gonna grab some water here
real quick so those were listening to
rest really sorry it's it's just my
mouth was dry it was drier than usual
keep him real man people said I've never
known actually keeping it real I'd be
crying if they were I was oppressed and
I've talked about this before my wife
didn't fully know how depressed I was
because I'd be up before her in the
morning and I'd be off to the gym before
she left for work and after the gym I
didn't know where I was headed in my
life wooden oars how did I just knew
that I had to keep moving but I decided
that it was the right time to fulfill a
lifelong dream I wanted my whole life I
wanted to have a dog again it's I know
it sounds silly but when you're a kid
and all you want is a dog and you cannot
have a dog it's a big deal so around
Christmas time five five years ago six
years ago I start looking on Petfinder
and I actually became a volunteer at a
local non-kill shelter which required a
certain level of training to even begin
with had the books I watched the
training videos
and I was gonna be the best dog owner
ever hopper popped up on Petfinder
and I remember the lady bring him to her
house and he was so nuts at first of
momentum with energy because he'd been
in a crate for so long and by the way I
want to make sure no one thinks that
this no she was not abusing the dog she
ran a rescue with her best friend and
she lost her best friend to cancer like
it's been a crappy 2019 one of my wife's
best friends just got diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer and obviously no it's
just it's been a rough a few months but
I'm still grateful it's a day above
ground and there people have it a whole
lot worse so people out there who have
it worse don't think that I'm comparing
my plight to yours
it's lady who ran the shelter anyway
that's what I was talking about she she
had a friend who ran it with her and not
a shelter a rescue they ran out of their
house but her friend died cancer and so
she was overwhelmed and she had to
create a lot of the dogs because not all
dogs get along and hopper had always
been a people dog he's a super easy dog
I mean you know this yeah as long as
he's around his people the reason he's
not in here now by the way you know he's
not dead people who are like where's
Happy's it's just because there are
other people around right now he'd
rather be in the room where the most
amount of people are but he doesn't do
well in a crate so he came in the house
he was buzzing around like crazy
he immediately rolled over put his paw
on me and you know licked my face but my
wife and I remember we decided that we
weren't just going to take the dog in
our first meeting we were going to talk
about it we were going to be disciplined
which that I remember the rescue lady
seemed really surprised
and I felt bad because she made a decent
trip out to us it was little ways and
she shouldn't have been so surprised at
that point she's effectively bringing a
fat three legged balding alopecia dog
with Lyme disease as you know I will
take it but he wasn't always the hopper
that you see today but I told her we'd
give her an answer the following day
like I said this was hopefully gonna tie
back in this is me taking time for me
here but we really had already decided
the next day we drove out we meet her we
made this lady between our place in her
place took him in our old Explorer was
it the tourists I don't know he ripped
the steering wheel off the tourists when
we took him to the outdoor shooting
range we parked a mile away and he still
heard he took the steering wheel off of
our Taurus I hope she told us that first
night she told us that we had to create
him that number how much he wailed
matter how much he complained that just
stick it through you got to put him in
the crate well that night he hold this I
mean his dog howled I came down the next
morning to find the crate was it looked
like the shark cage in Jaws after it'd
been torn apart by the by the real shark
they inserted documentary film footage
in that I was broken down he thrown up
he pooped in there and my wife and I
were actually on our way to the Rite Aid
for ear plugs to prepare for the next
night because well all we got to stick
this through when we came back we
realized that we hadn't crated him but
he was just sleeping in his bed fine
maybe he doesn't need it so we went to
church came back was in his bed didn't
so much as nibble a shoelace we went to
go see Captain America I don't member
which one it was at that point I came
back same and we've never really had a
problem with him ever since we haven't
had to create him he got into the trash
every now and then that's because my
wife left to slim jim on the top of the
trash at one point and it was open and
so he just thought oh the trash is a
place I go for James if it's on the top
you just pull it Costanza but it is
funny because when I heard what the
doctor said
I really could remember it's one of
those things people say your life
flashes before your eyes but when you're
about to lose something really important
everything that's important about that
person that thing floods every part of
your brain things that I didn't even
know were in there from how he's just
sleeping on my the bed next to my desk
and our den back when we did the show
and it was in a den he was right
next to my desk every single day used to
Ram his head if the door was closed just
boom oh you'd hear him crying and I
remembered serving him sardines on the
old front porch and trying to eat them
myself and almost throwing up I remember
teaching this to sit to stay and hurting
them to run out by the old East Grand
Rapids the eastern Rapids High School
track taking it up north for the first
time and particularly remember that
second night after the first night with
the crate I remember him just falling
asleep and my wife's arms in the futon
like he'd known her his whole life and
he's done it ever ever since every
single night
and I had to be in a schedule for opera
I had to live for something else who was
completely dependent on me and that's
why I think this is so hard cuz he can't
tell us you know that he's in pain
that's what's so hard you have to make a
decision out of wanting to avoid cruelty
and sometimes you have to make a
decision that is to end the life of
someone or something you care so much
about but at this point I remember I I
it gave me a purpose it made me more of
an adult and hopper make me happy he
makes me really happy and sometimes in
life you can pitch your flashpoint
moments that cut deeper than you've ever
felt in your life in that moment those
words are burned into your memory edge
to the walls of your soul forever and
when we found the news I remember my
wife tearing up and she said she said I
just wanted to bottle everything up
about hopper there is and just say it
she said this she just wanted to bottle
up everything that was about hopper and
just carry it with her forever that's
exactly how I feel and I feel terrible
that there's nothing I can do to help my
wife do that singing is terrible they
talk about toxic masculinity listen it
doesn't come from having to prove myself
it comes from loving my wife from trying
to provide for my wife from wanting to
burden that painted my wife because
we're called to do that as men as
Christians as believers in God yet
believers in Christ it's really painful
not just losing your best friend but
knowing how much pain your wife is in
and there's nothing you can do some
people get some great gifts in their
lives in hopper really was the best gift
I can I can talk about this a little bit
you everyone always says their dog is
special and I'm sure that's true to an
extent but believe me when I say that
Hopper really is special he changed
lives and I save you like I miss my dog
and it's just a dog that's you know
crapping around the house and they they
have no relationship with there's no
peace in the house
no hopper was change lives I don't just
mean in the sense that oh he changed our
lives or he brought lover to the house
he changed people's lives ask anyone on
the team he's probably changed a lot of
your lives ask anyone who's come to
visit people who don't even like dogs
loved hopper my aunt who was terrified
of dogs loved hopper wanted to get a dog
because of hopper kids who were
terrified of dogs loved hopper didn't he
didn't always love them back that's the
one thing hopper with the kids who were
rambunctious whacking him he didn't have
he would walk away but if he walked away
and you followed him you'd see the growl
you saw the hodgetwins good example in
this show freak when I introduced in the
hopper one of the funnies and everything
how about passed out in the show
laughing they were terrified what you
didn't see was the next time they came
over to my house and Hopper was there
they were sitting and petting her this
is even just as last time because he was
such a peaceful dog and he's by the way
I shouldn't say he was he is such a calm
dog and such a loving dog that he would
change people's hearts in views on dogs
he had a gift genuinely of melting away
fear and they wanted to make him a
therapy dog until he found out that he
didn't like sunglasses if you were
wearing sunglasses he might mess you up
so thank God we didn't make him a
therapy dog but that's why I'm going
through this in it being the most
painful thing I've experienced I'm
ashamed to say that at one point I
actually just thought when when this was
just happening and there was this
blinding pain the worst part was not
knowing what was happening right that's
what's true sometimes worse is the
anticipation than what actually happens
not knowing the answer whether it was
the aggressive cancer or there was a
slow-moving cancer at one point I
actually just thought of wanting to have
Betty our new puppy adopted not because
I don't love Betty but because I thought
I just could never go through this again
I really I thought I'll do anything to
avoid this kind of pain again at all
costs and then I realized how stupid and
ungrateful I was I probably never felt
more shame to myself in my life
that I was taking a gift did I prayed
for my whole life on my channel toad
spitting on it why because I didn't get
to keep it forever because as much as it
hurts I've gained so much more and I
really hope that for a three-legged dog
with alopecia and Lyme disease he would
say that I hope that I gave enough and I
realize that I felt that way before not
just about how I felt that way with this
show where things got so hard that I
wanted to throw it all away anything to
avoid the hell that I was going through
at that point ever again but I've gained
so much more you have given me so much
more in the same way I can only hope
that I've given enough so to take away
tonight and it's a cliche I know but
sometimes the tale as old as time is
that way for a simple reason and that's
because it's true I've talked about it
before is nothing new but genuinely be
grateful and something else too I
noticed we were sometimes you're really
praying and begging for something more
then you'll have gratitude for when you
actually get what you you asked for
because when we were praying please
please we just want this to be
aggressive cancer and then they told us
it probably wasn't we said well we
really really need to be thankful here
now then that was taken away from us
because it turned out that it was they
went back and forth get your facts
straight svet know they're good that say
they couldn't no he's a weird dog he's
tough to examine but sometimes you pray
for miracles and then don't believe that
they'll happen and I also noticed that
pain doesn't we used to say misery loves
company I don't think it's that so much
as pain doesn't love to be alone we
worked the vet and when we got that good
news at the oncologist I remember there
was a lady there with her dog Leia who
had mesothelioma and wasn't doing so
well
and we told her about hopper and we went
in and that was at the point when they
gave us better news and we came out and
she said yeah what did she seemed upset
she what news did you get and we could
tell she was upset and we said yeah you
know it's it's not good we just received
great news but we realized that she
would feel more alone if we said yeah
great news and her dog was probably not
going to make it with
so it really rough was pretty far along
because pain just doesn't want to be
alone and that's why I'm sure I try to
be as transparent as possible by the way
sharing something for the sake of
sharing it Jordan Peterson's talk if it
doesn't help anybody if it's not
something good a lot of people just
share sin a lot of people share their
faults and don't offer a solution well I
just don't want you to feel alone and so
they talk about mental health issues or
drugs well Hans you have a solution to
it otherwise you're not helping but
sharing pain the kind of pain that
everyone goes through it really does
help people no one left anomaly but if
we're gonna to have one takeaway this
week and now I'm just sort of circling
the runway I guess it really is simple
be grateful you've got a gift appreciate
it
share it because most gifts nearly all
gifts aren't for it and just because
it's not forever just because at some
point it may hurt it doesn't mean that
it's not a gift
and you don't have the right so I'll
keep you updated follow me on Instagram
and we'll talk about that sorry I was
[Music]